hey let's uh you know what kind of me
and you always have these talks about
kind of like you're you have a pretty
unique path to where you are right now
yes most uh
like you're a new artist but you're not
a new artist I'm a new artist well
you're a new artist to the world but I
feel like your grind is not new for sure
like um kind of give us a little bit of
background on just like
give me let's start at like when you
were running around with DJ amen wow so
um you were managing artist too yeah so
before I actually wanted to be an artist
I was managing artists right so it was
an artist named young Kurt shout out to
Young Kirk
um a lot of people know Kirk music you
remember the [ __ ] on my mama that girl
no yeah so Kurt had like a bunch of
songs and we were running around and I
was just telling this story earlier like
Kurt was like
not the most friendly person you know so
it was kind of tough to like get him to
talk to program directors and promoters
yeah Network and do the [ __ ] you got to
do yeah so I naturally had to go do that
work yeah which kind of made me more of
a people person and understood how to
talk to people and deal with people in
Industry so me and Kurt ran into some
differences and I started doing my own
thing and just me naturally seeing what
it took to kind of like cut through I
applied that to what it was I was doing
the problem was my music was just
terrible at the time right so people
arrived with me as a person but the
music wasn't all the way there so I
would notice that I would notice when I
play my music and somebody else would
play something I'd be like damn my [ __ ]
wasn't hitting like that right got
around a bunch of different songwriters
a bunch of different producers signed my
first deal at Columbia
immediately realized I wasn't a priority
in the building when I realized I wasn't
a priority in the building about a week
later it was a regime change where
everybody who signed me over there and
brought me in and left and went to a new
label right so I was stuck on this label
being a traditional rapper that got
signed through writing a song for
somebody else and they wanted me to make
music that type of way what would you
write a song for I can't tell you that
okay I can't tell you that but it's a
well-known rapper
um Columbia no oh from New York though
oh no but not nas Legend okay
um not nice not nice okay
um so I was writing this song and they
wanted me to continue to do that Jay-Z
but it was like no it was like some
Melody right younger new guy right no
okay
um so
so I kept going and
I did that because I was basically broke
at the time yeah I used all my money
moving out here right right so I was
running around buying people drinks
buying tables every night thinking this
is what'll get me known right wasting a
bunch of [ __ ] money artists don't
ever think buying DJs and buying table
buying DJ's drinks and buying it doesn't
matter it's going to change your career
it only works when your music is
actually it's got to be dope yeah get
the music first and then do that I
actually like it if I'm DJing and
someone and a rapper comes up to me and
gets me a drink I I hate it yeah cause
now I feel like you're using me no I
just feel like
I know this guy thinks I'm going to play
a song and I feel like he's using you
I'm not gonna play the songs I'd almost
rather just you keep the drink exactly
yeah you know so I went through that
whole phase and then
um around 2019 I ran into Dallas Martin
yeah and Dallas is like
he's like the a r that's like always
taking the chance like right he signed
Roddy like he's not really just signing
you because of your following or because
you got a hit record he's signing you
because he believes and he's trying to
change the trajectory of things of how
they may be yeah I feel like that's how
people should get signed based off of
the gut based off the music not off the
metrics the problem is is people like
bullet Kev that caused my album number
five and and all these other records get
streamed because of what he just said
but that's neither here nor there so
people like Dallas got to take a chance
on me because people like bullet Kev
calls my album number five okay so
shouts out to Dallas Martin for taking
that chance because without him I'd just
be number five
so shout out to Dallas
you're a dick